meanwhile across America's statues are
being toppled streets and schools have
been renamed or in the middle of a
revolution
remember all for the sake of purging the
memory of long ago racism but in New
York they have a very different plan
they're now honoring a genocide all
dictator amazing the City Council led by
Jumaane Williams who's a frequent guest
on this show if you watch you'll know
exactly who he is running for lieutenant
governor of New York right now
just voted to rename a street after the
Haitian dictator jean-jacques Dessalines
in the early 1800s dessaline ordered the
genocide of all white people on the
island that included men women and
children and he did it it's what he is
best known for New York City apparently
finds that impressive so impressive
they're gonna name a street after him
Seth Baron is associate editor of city
journal he joins us tonight
Seth thanks up for coming on did did I
for state that no you were right
you were right okay so what is this
about yeah it will go exactly well you
know I think it would make perfect sense
to have a statue or a street named after
John Jacques dessaline in port-au-prince
the Haitian capital I don't understand
why we're doing it in New York City I
mean there are a number of Haitians here
in Brooklyn yes near there but you know
this is advocated by the same people
Jumaane Williams and others who want to
tear down the statue of Columbus at
Columbus Circle who want to rename you
know Stuyvesant High School because
Stuyvesant owned slaves so it's a very
extreme kind of measure I mean if you
recall a year ago Jumaane Williams was
very much in favor of the Puerto Rican
Day Parade
honoring Oscar Lopez Rivera I know you
had him on then Oscar Lopez Rivera was a
terrorist who bombed a major historic
landmark downtown and killed several
people including a cop but this is who
you know there is that this is who the
city is now apparently honoring and
favoring what such that mean there are a
couple of interesting things about this
but the first is that multiculturalism
isn't real so we were told that
multiculturalism is when lots of
cultures kind of coexist it happily
and all that this is really destroying
one culture and replacing it with the
with the new a foreign culture that
appears to be we're taking your
monuments down and putting ours up I
mean that's kind of what's going on well
I talked to one member of the City
Council a Republican who voted for it
for this street renaming and he sort of
indicated that this was like insurance
or a soft this way this this will
protect Columbus like if we give them
this street for after day saline then
they won't come after Columbus and I
said that's like the strategy of feeding
your friends to the crocodiles in hopes
that they'll eat you last you know I
think that they'll have dessaline and
take Columbus eventually when they want
to when they're ready but Columbus
discovered America and this is America
so maybe there's a reason we celebrate
Columbus dessaline whatever I'm sure you
had good points in addition to being a
genocide on that case sure you know no
one is monochromatic but like what does
it have to do with America nothing is
complicated history is complicated and
everybody I know has there has they're
mixed you know they're mixed story
according to Jumaane Williams Columbus
Jefferson Washington it's all arbitrary
why they're honored and dessaline or
Miyabi I guess aren't so guess that's
next Mugabe yes that Baron City Journal
there's great story thank you for that
very much we're gonna talk to Johnny
Williams I think next week about this